but that's it the problem for myself
because for my philosophy individuality
is of no importance of us so my identity
is my ideas they are much more important
than myself my personality my biography
because my biography is mine by
bibliography I would say so I am
philosopher russian philosopher I'm
trying to understand the identity of
Russia history the logic of Russian
history
I try to understand the place of modern
Russia in the world and it is impossible
without studying the roots of the
history of the other nations other
cultures so I am trying to understand
where we are who we are where we are
going that is kind of my presentation I
all my life I do nothing else than
trying to understand what is going on
and how it has happened and where we are
came for I am rejecting the Liberals but
because liberalism is the universal
dogma so I'm challenging what everybody
thinks
or the kind of ground ideological ground
of contemporary con-con contemporary
world so that is really dangerous if it
is successful for example if if I would
be a kind of insignificant insignificant
insect trying to to address the huge
construction that is prosperous and
without problem I wouldn't be judged
dangerous so that is a real recognition
of my efforts in order to put liberals
under question but the most important
and all that why it is really dangerous
because I am against all
forms of anti liberalism that belong to
the past and first of all I am
anti-communist and anti-fascist because
these two forms of anti liberalism
belong to the Past and I'm I'm trying to
attack liberalism from the future from
the present AeroGarden
liberalism as it is and trying to
understand his logic his change in its
essence and what could be opposed to it
not from the perspective of the past but
from a kind of Kevin Holmes metaphysical
ground outside of modernity it's not
before to modernity or into the pre
liberal maternity modernity of communism
or fascism I like to think outside of
the limits of liberalism and not trying
to to reduce its danger parts or to
improve or adjust it I think the
proposal is absolutely wrong not because
of liberalism because of modernity
because modernity liberal was liberal
from the beginning it was not so clear
from the beginning that individualism
will will finally over socialism or
nationalism but now it is clear and that
was indeed allistic roots of the Western
modernity that is wrong that the concept
of the men of the human being as an
individual is individual is wrong so I
am trying to to challenge that trying to
propose alternative anthropology in
order to fight against liberalism and if
liberals who are prevailing
model world judge me most dangerous
philosopher I for me it is pleasure
so first of all I think that liberalism
considered the subject of the freedom as
individual so that is already a
limitation of the freedom next step idea
of liberalism it is only negative
freedom the Liberty that negative
freedom means that liberals depend on
Liberty from and not freedom for that
was in the MU in the instance in the
central founders of liberalism so a
negative kind of freedom is real and has
content when you compare liberalism with
not liberal system for example a
traditional society or in the modernity
with all totalitarian regimes as
communism or fascism so in that case the
British is operative is working because
the negative freedom is the negative
from absence of freedom represented in
totalitarian or authoritarian regime so
it is something real but when all these
regimes are formed by liberalism and
that was the case in the nineteen one
when Fukuyama Kakuma from time to time
have debates very fruitful as long as I
concern myself at least so when he has
declared the end of history that was
completely rightful remark because that
was the end of comparison between
liberalism and communism so from now on
there was only one political ideology
prevailing on the world scale that was
liberalism but in that situation there
appear the limits of liberalism because
it the liberty of
Prison is real comparing with communist
or fascist miss totalitarianism when
liberalism is compared to itself it
becomes totalitarian and it begins to
show its inner negativity on one hand
and other hand it begins to manifest its
totalitarian nature because now you are
free in the world where we're living on
the present and that has won in that
position liberalism give us the freedom
to be liberal and it takes off the
freedom to be a liberal you could be in
the liberal society right liberal left
liberal you could be far left flipper a
PEZ melodrama or Bernie Sanders you
could be as well in some special cases
far-right but liberals but still the
birds you should be you are free in the
real of liberalism you are free to
believer and you are not free to be a
liberal or not leader so there that the
second totalitarian that appeared after
precisely the victory or clincher in
victory of liberalism and we should deal
with this status quo not project or the
shadows of the past not compare
liberalism with communism corporations
it that all belongs to the past now that
that materialism the Orval or rather
Huxley is precisely in the liberalism
the challenge to the freedom and the
most important enemy of the freedom now
is the negative freedom of totalitarian
liberalism and I am calling the third
totalitarianism
first was communist ii fishes and now
when we have done with of first and
second two platoons we are dealing
welcome to the third totalitarian
and that is the there are my criticism
of Io politic of globalization and of
United States of America that United
States of America at least before Trump
came to power became a kind of symbol
for this globalization of this
liberalism of this unique polarity with
one set of wings when one American life
impose as something inevitable as a kind
of destiny to all the humanity and that
is why I'm against them but the most
important situation that we need to
secure the freedom from liberalism
because now liberalism is openly the
opponent of the real freedom but it is
I'm absolutely sure that it will make
the step behind
so in communist or inflation we could
not find the real freedom we need to
find real freedom elsewhere not inside
of modernity not in liberalism but
outside of the prison but as well
outside of communism and fascism
so that is invitation to think beyond
these limits and that is the the sense
of my fourth political theory both your
friends and your enemies claim that
flirting meet Putin is listening to you
so it must be true
why is he listening to you I am trying
first of all to give way to ideas that
I'm Plutonians
politicians so I I believe in existence
of ideas independently from the man so
and I'm in service of ideas and I'm
Russian so my ideas with necessity
Russian ideas so I am trying to give way
to Russian idea to I'm trying to to help
them to appear and that was a kind of
the book of Russian ideas and Putin
look into these books not written by
Alexander but the books of Russian ideas
for me it is important to give way to
explain to propose not my will or my
special conventions but to reveal what
we have forgotten during communism what
we have lost during our party debates
between the left and right communists is
the Liberals and I'm trying to to create
the kind of Russian dictionary of ideas
so Putin is regarded as regarding their
and from time to time takes what he
thinks are useful in practice so I'm
trying to understand first and direct
after and understanding is the path is
philosophical at at and we could not
claim that political leader have have
the possibility to spend so time so many
time as maybe he would like to in order
go to this art of understanding